محمد صابر
قديح سته كنا
قاعدين اختي لارين ولمار وانا ونجاح وين
قاعدين وشعب رفه الجلوس مع بعض
اه فقد عيله
ابني اربع انفار هم امهم وابني
متغرب وقعد 15 سنه لما جاب الولد هذا
والولد هذا كان معهم كان مع العيله بلكن
ربنا خلاه عشان ابوه بده يعمر البيت البيت
استكر ماتوا كليتهم يا اخوي كلهم ماتوا
فيش غير الطفل
هذا كنا كنا بنلعب ضربوا علينا صاروخ طاحت
علينا الدار وكان معي اكشاف بالنص طويت
وطلعنا واحنا واحنا وبنت خالي حكي لي فيك
الشاف ضواي وانا مشيت مشيت مشيت وطلعت هيك
لقيت جبل اللي هو اربع طوابق جبل كبير
نزلت من على الجبل ونزلت من عليه الا بقول
شوي بعدين بحكي اخذوني في الاسعاف وخدوني
على
المستشفى كان مع امه دايما مسكته ودايما
وشاطر وفهمان والحين بيجري هيك مش عارف
كيف عشان بقول بدي اروح لامي بدور علي
بصيح بقول امي امي بتستنى فيا طب امبارح
بقول امي بتستنى فيا قعدها بتدور علي مش
دار عن حاله امبارح يعني اشترينا له علبه
لبن بحكي له خذ اشرب حكي لي لا ماما عندها
في البيت موجود في البيت عند ماما الولد
يعني صغير ايش ذنب الاطفال مش مش مفرط فيه
لا انا ولا عمامه عمامه كمان بربه فيه مش
مش مفرطين فيه هو نتفت الوحيد اللي ظل
ابني يعني انت
عارف ابو نكي
هو رايح الغربه لبناء مستقبل ابنائه هو
اصلا متشوق لهم والله العظيم متشوق
لرؤيتهم والله بتصل على امبي دائما بكي
لها انا بدي ار لا هو هدفه بحكي انا هدفي
بدي اشتري قطعه ارض وارفع رصيد للانا
واخواتها للجامعات وانا بروح فجا يرنوا
علي يحكوا اولادك كلهم ضاعوا استشهدوا في
هذه الحرب الجبانه حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
نفسيتنا يعني نفسيه الناجي الوحيد محمد في
هذا
الحرب الذنب الاطفال تضيع في حرب ما لها
داعي في حرب احنا ش ذنبنا احنا شو زلب
احنا في المدنيين بطب في الناس في
الاطفال